I wanted to ask you what what triggers
your anxiety because a reason I asked
that question is I'm a far more anxious
person than you man I'll tell you
social media used to trigger my anxiety
okay before like when I was following a
bunch of people which I I'd still like
following I think us on Twitter and on
Instagram I think I might be falling
moriah and on Instagram but dude like
looking at social media and whether it
was an article about something really
bad happening that was shared whether it
was someone responding to a critic or
going on a rant man like it was a very
it can be a very big anxiety inducing
experience but I'll tell you man like
since I have like cleared my whole
stream yeah like now dude it's been such
an awesome experience like today I was
on Twitter and I saw I saw people who
were donating to the the gem city fund
that we have right now where we're
trying to build that co-op in Dayton
Ohio yeah like that's really awesome
very very encouraging right someone
reached out to me and they're like hey
you know I was listening to that that
podcast where you lost your air pods and
you know you can go and actually go on
the Find My iPhone app and find your ear
pods which I really appreciate the tip
don't get me wrong right I mean of
course I went on and tried to do that
and I didn't get anything but my point
is is that now by changing my approach
with social media I am and I am able to
like really enjoy that experience so
much more man yeah I'm able to interact
with with people who comment a lot more
where it used to be so I don't get a ton
of comments it's not like I get a
thousand people reaching out to me today
but I will get you know 5 to 10 10 to 20
items on some days and even if I would
get only your personal copy yeah just on
my personal account gets yes yeah but
but now when I so I used to see like
just five notifications hey you've got
five notifications people are mentioning
you or anyone stressed me out because I
hadn't even gone through my feed yet
right and like browse through that yeah
but now it's like that's that has 100%
of my attention
why here Instagram added this feature of
that you're all caught up now
oh yeah I don't know because I don't
have Instagram on my phone but I if I do
want to post something I'd download it
and then I post the thing and I'd like
to lead it which I'm sure hurts me
algorithmically but I don't give a [ __ ]
and I'll do the rhythms yeah right
formas we're not mathematicians math
podcast but the the the thing with
Instagram is like you're now caught up
feature to me is like both
anxiety-producing and relieving at the
same time which is a perfect metaphor
what for what you were just talking
about I think because what you were
talking about is hey as I was using
Instagram and or not interested
Instagram but any social media platform
sometimes it pacifies our instant
anxiety so yeah I'm saying to
distraction
yeah exactly so I'm gonna stand in line
at Chipotle let me quickly I'm feeling
anxious because I'm not doing anything
with my hands or my mind or whatever I
need to I need some sort of distraction
but in a weird way by covering up the
immediate anxiety it just extends the
anxiety it's like taking a pill that
covers up the symptoms without without
really dealing with the problem now all
that to say that we're not saying social
media is inherently bad or evil it can
be quite useful what you're saying is
some in in some manner you're actually
rediscovering the useful aspects of the
communicative side of social media and
then of course when we redid our social
media plan earlier this year where we
basically said hey we're gonna use
social media completely differently in
2018 we want to be very intentional
about how we are using social media when
we did that we wanted to be
communicative but also expressive what's
the best way we can express ourselves
and add value to other people's lives
and how can I use social media to add
value to my life and man you're right if
we don't instantly I feel more anxious
in this anxiety-producing so I wrote
down a few things that that there's a
joke that I often start some of our
events with about there are three things
that I hate I hate large crowds of
people travel and public speaking and of
course you know we've gone on over I
think 300 tour stops at this point and
all over
North America Australia and Europe and
we're headed to Brazil next month for a
private event so like I actually don't
hate these things but they do make me
anxious travel yeah makes me anxious
being around people makes me more
anxious and I do with anxiety you know I
don't say I hide it really well it's not
that I hide it but I don't find it
useful to like go around exposing my
anxiety and trying to make other people
think I think I think it's important to
have some anxiety with things I mean
that that stress that we feel is an
indicator mm-hmm and that's why it's
there that's why it's built into us I
think it is it is something that lets us
know something is wrong but that warning
light in your car we backs and I were
driving in her Prius this weekend from
Missoula to Bozeman mm-hmm and we were
driving there one of the indicator
lights came off like low tire pressure
yeah that tells you something
something's up wrong Yeah right but to
sit there and ruminate over that light
being on and to sit there and talk to
Beck's and and stress until that light
finally comes off right it's it's
useless rumination like I love that
whole bit in our documentary with Dan
Harris talks about going to the airport
and you know there is a bit of anxiety
even for me when I know I've left the
airport left for the airport with plenty
of time there's always this bit of
anxiety room like whoa what if traffic
all of a sudden you know it takes twice
as long to get there and I got to get
there on time and that is very useful
anxiety to a certain extent but when we
get stuck in the rumination yes I think
that's where anxiety is is definitely
hurtful and then the other thing too
which I'm totally guilty of this is like
for example with social media like I
know that that has a big chance it used
to have a big chance of causing me
distress so I did I was doing two things
wrong a I kept looking at it so I kept I
kept inducing that anxiety I knew I had
a chance of inducing anxiety and the
other thing is I
I just wasn't using it as deliberate as
I should have all right so I wrote down
this note that goes along with exactly
what you're saying here I don't know
what
fit in in the podcast but this is the
perfect time I wrote down if you go
searching for anxiety you will find it
oh yeah and I think that there are in
the sources of things like that
statement just made me a little anxious
because I know there's something there
like all of a sudden like I'm like oh
crap leg I got to move out of my
apartment in 30 days and I had a place
so I told my landlord I was leaving but
now I don't have a place right like
there's always something and then you
start going to like the worst-case
scenario right oh my god leave it for
dude I really am getting anxious about
this just thinking about it
right going on tour not gonna be back
till the 29th I have only two weeks to
look for a place oh my god yes you're
getting ready to move you found the
apartment but then someone like put in a
better offer than you and all of a
sudden now you are you're living in the
studio now yeah it's great though the
floors here are really clean think about
that as an option we have my storage
unit you were telling me about what else
makes me so if people make me they don't
I don't actually hate these these things
they make me anxious right drabble makes
me anxious and we're recording this
right before we go on the simply
southern tour by the time this comes out
we will have already been in Birmingham
and Louisville and I think tonight will
be if you're listening to this today it
comes out tonight will be Nashville with
with Rachael Cruz but we were going to
go travel and I get anxiety just
thinking about it in fact I was flying
to Montana last but last week and like
that made me anxious I just just did not
a lot of anxiety but enough that I'm
like oh oh I this is a warning sign this
is some sort of indicator light right
and then the question then is do I just
leave that indicator light on and and
just continue to worry about it or do I
do something about it here a few other
things that make me anxious anxious
stressed me out more than one cup on the
table that's true one of me so I have
OCD right I mean like a doctor actually
told me I have OCD but I don't need a
doctor to tell me that I walked down 49
steps from the parking garage
this morning literally to get here right
there is an office on the other side of
us where a guy has six pins on his desk
this morning and I'm like what is he
doing why doesn't he have three that's
the perfect number
everyone knows the appropriate number of
ten no it's so like I noticed these
things I'm Way more obsessive than I am
compulsive but I just noticed these
things and so something else that really
makes me anxious is parenting hmm I
realized that you know especially this
week Ella was being a bit of a handful
and she could be really fun and and you
Rob Bell says you're your first job as a
parent is to enjoy your kids you know to
me that is like my biggest aspiration in
life is to find ways to to enjoy Ella as
a as a human being and as a child and I
was able to do that last night you know
we had to go get money for the the
laundry machines away I give her a $20
bill to get quarters out she thinks
she's hit the slot machine jackpot and
she loves him we were like looking at
the lights outside our window and she
was like that one's pink and I we I
wasn't able to enjoy her from time to
time but then there are the times where
you're able to enjoy it from time to
time yeah that's good
yeah but there are times like in the
same hour where I'm like oh you're not
listening and like it's truly well are
you acting like you're five right it's
truly anxiety-producing for me it's at
the point where it's like I'm
overwhelmed with with anxiety and so if
people make me anxious Travel makes me
anxious parenting makes me anxious
public speaking makes me anxious clutter
makes me anxious for sure but we just
talked about the pins or whatever but
but yeah in my own in my own space is
especially the spaces that I have
control over we were just going through
this earlier I'm like hey can we put
away that lens cap and can we put away
Ryan's good laptop which they weren't
bothering anyone they weren't ugly or
anything but these are just things that
that bother me
debt debt really stresses me out
thankfully I haven't had debt in a long
that is God that's probably when I think
about all the stresses in my life
I think debt is by far the biggest
stress I've ever put on myself I can't
think of anything else it's like that's
a good woman yeah and it's the thing
about dead is you you just said it
perfectly it's the thing that we put on
ourselves
oh yeah someone else generally doesn't
pour debt on you there could be a sort
of medical it's legal for here Josh I
just bought you a house here's the team
$400,000 grab your hair babies make you
sign yeah and so so that is really
stressful and and it was a stressor it
was a low-level stressor because I just
sort of ignored it that that warning
light was on my entire 20s and then
obviously in my early 30s until I got
out of debt 31 32 and and that light was
just there and you can't ignore it
because it's flashing all the time yeah
and so you just sort of pretend it's not
there it becomes part of your everyday
existence flash flash flash flash I used
to tell myself because someone had told
someone had told me you know it's good
to have a little bit of stress and
that's what I would tell myself when I
felt that indicator and with the net
yeah it's like oh I'm supposed to have a
little bit of stress in my life yeah but
in you know there are the majority of
the people living in the United States
are in debt so you know I'm not saying
that if you have that like you know it's
this is such a touchy subject for me man
because what I want to say is is yes we
put it on ourselves yes and the amount
of debt that I had that was giving me
anxiety it was too much debt and yes I
should have been an indicator for me to
like to change it yeah I think most
people United States either have that or
have had that at some point in time yeah
and if you have that you're broke I mean
there's no other way to really say it if
there's means you can't afford the thing
they see you're much more direct when it
comes to the debt than I am but here's
but here I'm saying this in loving way
like the way the way I would say it to
Ella when she's 15 or 16 and I would say
hey if you have that you're broke but
here's here's the good news we've all
been broke or broken at some period in
time that's okay what
not okay is to continue to be broke or
broken without a plan to get out of that
brokenness that that we are experiencing
and so being in debt can be okay if you
have a plan to get out of there's no
such thing as good debt and I know we
say that repeatedly I can't wait to talk
to Chris and Anthony and Rachel about
this because I know a they'll agree but
their money experts and they'll have a
lot more to say about the topic in a way
that's way more articulate than I can
articulate it extemporaneously but I I
think that but by realizing that there
is this anxiety whether it is with the
clutter or with parenting or with travel
or with debt whatever it might be STD
tests those really give me anxiety it's
like the worst anxiety yet even though
like I mean now it's okay cuz like we're
monogamous but yeah right you know what
though that's not true
I mean it's true that woman ah I didn't
realize even Bex had an arrangement man
I mean we'll talk about that in a
separate episode but it's it's more
arranged than you might think but anyway
that there's when I look at STD testing
I had to do I was reopening my life
insurance then they sent you to go do
all the blood tests and whatever and I
have no reason to think I would have any
sort of I mean I've done so many blood
tests over the last three years but even
then I'm like waiting to get it back and
I'm like what if they missed it all the
other seventeen times I've had Nestor
only those things are only 99.9 percent
accurate right and I went from one of
the point one percent yeah but it's it
is true like that those little things
will cause stress food yeah whatever
reason absolutely man and so so so how
do you deal with stress man so so I
think that with these anxiety producing
things the reason I don't show it
outwardly as much in fact when I do show
it hourly it usually comes off as
annoyance and so people often think I'm
annoyed by things it's really because
I'm anxious inside right but I I work
hard to not show what outwardly cuz that
just makes other people anxious I don't
know and that's not what I want is that
if I ask myself what's my desired
outcome well I really want everyone else
in the room to be anxious too that's
gonna help my anxiety
of course not that's gonna make my
anxiety worse imagine if everyone around
you is super super anxious all of a
sudden you're gonna even be more anxious
even if you didn't start out anxious
you're gonna have a heightened sense of
anxiety and so for me it's about it's
what you have one of two options there
you can remove the a thing that produces
your anxiety and you could become an
agoraphobe and lock yourself in your
house and then you're still I mean
they're the most anxious people in the
world still are the people who are
agoraphobe right and I could totally see
myself going toward that you know like
the Howard Hughes thing he was the total
or agoraphobia and it so so that's one
option is okay well I'll never travel
ever again okay I'll stop being a parent
I'm gonna have to leave Bex and and no
more parenting for Ella because she just
stresses me out too much I'm too anxious
with that and so I'm gonna get rid of
that with clutter well you know what I'm
just going to going to have to not own
anything at all in my life because
anything that I own is going to make me
anxious I'm never gonna speak in public
again because that's gonna make me
anxious so that's one way to try to deal
with anxiety that's not the best way to
do it well yeah if you will a at that
point you'd be setting the expectation
that you're gonna live your life stress
free or a free of anxiety right and
that's just that's a really bad
expectation yes and so some stressors
some anxiety is really useful those are
those indicator lights that you talked
about and so for me when I start feeling
anxious about something it means I need
to take action I need to I need to be
brave enough to lean into this and
figure out what is actually making me
anxious
about parenting what is actually making
me anxious about travel and then how do
I deal with that what is actually wrong
with the car when we were in Montana and
that light came on you know what it was
actually a bad indicator light and so so
it wasn't we saw what a metaphor do
because sometimes were born with bad
indicator lights exactly and so I got
out of it we pulled over the side of
i-90 and I got out I checked all the
tires make sure there was no no problem
or the sensor would it was a bad
indicator sensor either sensor was off
right yeah yeah the the sensor was often
so what I did was I went around I
checked all of the the
the lights and era the tires and they
were all fine and then we stopped a few
miles down the road again and checked
and make sure everything was okay
and eventually the light went off but
now that all that tells me is hey we can
eed to go to the Toyota dealership and
they have to reset the sensor or maybe
replace the sensor yeah and so how do we
replace our sensors and our own lives
you